like the Articles written about me using
he pronouns and calling me a man over
and over again and I I feel like that
should be illegal I I don't know that's
that's just bad journalism so if that's
illegal then it should also be illegal
for you to call yourself a woman because
you're not so let's just get out of that
Dylan because it's not reality and free
speech is free speech and I don't have
to call you anything any fake name or
pronoun that you you want me to lie
basically he wants us to become Liars
he's lying about about his biology it's
a Cinderella I refuse he's lying about
his biology and he wants us to lie and
if not he wants us to face penalties
under the law it should be illegal to
misgender someone though what does he
mean is that a criminal misdemeanor or
is it a felony how bad is this Dylan how
much does it hurt your feelings I feel
so sorry for this man because he is so
crazy he's batshit crazy out of his mind
yeah you know and that's really sad I
mean I you'd think that this whole thing
was a joke like if if his videos were
showed 30 years ago you would think it
was just satire like a woman wearing
heels in the woods or buying tampons
that's actually a dude like this you
think that it was a joke quite literally
to be honest 30 years ago we would have
enjoyed his entertainment because he was
so ridiculous but when now that it's
paired with propaganda being told when
teenagers are being told and little
children are being told that they're
born in the wrong body and that they can
mutilate their bodies and they can take
hormones to stop their puberty and stop
and [__] with their biology and mess
with nature that's the problem so he's
just coming in at the wrong time because
you're right 30 years ago this just
would have been entertainment we might
have thought he was hilarious and hired
him to come and perform at a party now
you're part of something sinister and
dark it's crazy so go to hell Dylan I
have something else to watch oh this is
the so-called activists are harming the
group that they're claiming to advocate
for as well as harming 51 of the of the
whole human population because let's be
real all of this stuff all the negative
Downstream impacts are on girls on women
they are not on boys and men at all I'd
say this whole thing is incredibly
misogynist that's the thing the whole
conversation it's about men thinking
they're women nobody gives a [__] about
the women that think they're men because
they can't [__] do anything special
what are you gonna what are you gonna
join a men's thing and then take over
anything no you're not gonna do [__] so
that's why no one's really talking about
that yeah it's crazy like you're
literally just hurting yourself all
these feminists they hate men but then
they want men to play in their Sports
and [__] on women it doesn't make any
sense it's actually crazy Township
that's the exact explanation so he says
um that all of the men and women's
sports you know that all of the effects
Downstream are you know aren't women
there is a small group of men who who
have gender dysphoria and who think
they're women who are not looking to
harm children who are not looking to
play in women's sports and they are
fully innocent of all of it and they are
being hurt by this they're just they're
being hurt by the extremists just being
crazy on their own dick and I don't like
to throw that word around too much today
conversation up a level as well I have a
question and the whole thing is why are
we trying to force people and why are so
many people entertaining the denial of
reality itself yeah women's rights are
incredibly important fairness in sports
is important safety and security and
privacy all of these things are very
important the fundamental problem at the
root of this is everyone dancing around
pretending that a man can truly be a
woman and a woman can truly be a man
this is not me being transphobic or
hateful or being a bigot anything like
that it's simply that reality exists
biology is real and is that reality
legal one because in this country is
that you can change your gender you
cannot change your biological sex it's
physically impossible I'm I'm saying to
you it is impossible
can you change your biology we can talk
about biology and we can talk about the
legality we're talking about biology
though we're talking this thing is about
sport this is about males and females
well the problem when we talk about
biology is yeah so I could legally
identify as blind but I don't have to
Yeah by her logic yes you can legally
identify as a blind black woman this is
just I I don't even know stupid like you
you analyze it you analyze the
chessboard of what you could say and
what you can counter them with and it's
just like it doesn't require much
analysis no it's like it does it doesn't
that's the thing like I I just said this
like you can think of all the crazy
things to say that might make something
click in their brain but it's just like
no like a guy can't become a girl like
this is all this is delusion that's all
that I have XX chromosomes you have X Y
chromosomes it's that simple
this is the thing this that that she
just hit it so they keep that's that
what they're saying it's a lot more
complicated they have them all with
these talking points where they'll say
it's complicated it is not complicated
it is very very it's actually one of the
most simple things like the second
you're born that's the first thing you
know boil it all down any problem you
have in your life the simplest answer is
the right answer it always is I was
assigned male at Birth I wasn't born a
male yeah you are born a mile you were
signed no so she's saying it's
complicated it's complicated if you are
mentally ill and you make it complicated
it's complicated if you decide to twist
and bend the truth and pretend that
reality isn't reality but that doesn't
mean it that it is correct and it is
right and it is true it's not
complicated it's simple out of all the
[__] I have to worry about in my life
from business to spending as little time
on my phone as possible keeping as much
Consciousness being able to speak as
clearly and concisely as possible
everything that I care about Mama of
course everything that I care about I
couldn't imagine drawing into the mix
that I could be a girl all it is is just
extra confusion like once you're telling
kids and stuff this it's just extra
[__] cluttering their brain but it's
again sunny it's the it's this culture
that has that has disease this rot that
has permeated our culture over the last
30 40 50 years that everything is about
me and my mind and what's going on in my
head and you know if if we taught kids
to think about their Community their
society their family their God think
about real value the the Liberals
sitting thinking about how uncomfortable
they are in their body and and that they
might not be what they were born I mean
this is brainwashing these kids into
being completely unhinged I know I know
it's insane and if you don't and if I
don't honor your fur this fantasy it's
not gender affirming it's fantasy
affirming if I don't affirm your fantasy
I identify as you're gonna Arnold
Schwarzenegger threaten me with suicide
yeah I got you you know what you know in
relationships you you'll hear it all the
time somebody say oh I broke up with him
and he told me he was going to kill
himself so I so I stayed with him or a
girl will do that to a guy that's it's
abortion threatening suicide if you
don't get your way it's crazy
I think we we're being you were
indulging and ignorant can you cannot
suggest can you become can you become
can you talk about Indulgence I don't
want to be a candle is there anything
that could be done that could turn you
into a male in the way that I'm a male
and peers as well is that is that
possible now do you see how you've
qualified your question so you first
trust me
can I become in the mail and I would
suggest probably yes in terms of
medically but then then you said then
you said like you and peace and that's
where we start to get comfortable I hope
we would have taken you a little further
down your journey
when you say you think you can become
male you can't because male
legally become a male we've got legally
you still legally be able to have slaves
too sweetheart yeah how about that
there's a lot of things that that are
legal or worly I love how they just they
hate the government but then they'll bow
down to the law with stuff like this it
used to be that only a man could ask for
divorce legally was that right take away
the right to vote I'm joking yeah no
you're right though yeah women legally
could not vote oh let's just leave it
alone it's fine just because you say
you're a man or you say you're a woman
crazy if your biology does not affirm
that you know what it was too like that
I just not real is the only the reason
the men voted was not only because the
men got all the [__] done like that
still happens but you voted as as a as a
family and as a household so then once
that they had they had the women be able
to put it that way huh I've never heard
it put that way it makes sense though
when you're when you actually have
families together and your your values
are aligned then you just vote as a
family I guess it made sense for that
time and but I I but then once they say
once they get rid of that and then the
women can also vote now that's double
the people that can vote essentially
right that is that's yeah that's double
yeah and then now you just have to push
all this propaganda separate the family
that way you can win their votes and
then you can retain control it's crazy
yeah I I think and then and then I think
and then it also takes the kids out of
the household and then programs the kids
right I I do think that the step to to
let women vote to give women the right
to vote because it is right
um I don't think that that was the the
thing that was the demise of society
though no that's not what I'm saying
because they were because women were
affected women are deeply affected by
the policies and the laws of this
country because we are half the
population so we absolutely should have
had the right to vote all the other
things about destroying the family and
keeping us separated from each other and
making sure the families don't have you
know solid common values I do agree that
there are you know that there have been
mechanisms put in place to make that
happen yeah I'm not saying women
shouldn't be able to vote but it makes
sense like why back in the day that that
it was because back then women got
husbands and they made families you just
voted as family that's the way it was so
I mean it's not
it's not crazy of a thing to say back
then yeah yeah I know that's what I'm
saying I understand for back then but
whatever I I just I look but just stop
for a second that you know what his what
his tweet said is that he he his mind is
boggled that he had an actual woman
sitting in front of him who is convinced
that a man can become a woman and take
her place and be as much of a woman as
she is like no you're never gonna you're
never gonna be you're never gonna be a
woman ever you have to take crazy drugs
that will probably give you tumors and
God only knows what I know it's not like
the drugs actually make you into the
other gender if they actually made you
into the other gender this might make a
little bit more sense if I could
actually become a woman but you're not
you're not actually becoming a woman
you're just taking hormones that got
only God knows what they're gonna do to
you and it's gender affirming it's
life-saving gender affirming like how
does this mean you can't get past but
then you gotta believe us follow the
science follow this follow the science
yeah that's what they say follow the
science the irony the irony of that it's
absolutely ridiculous but all right I'm
done with this [__] thank you so
much for watching make sure to like
subscribe I'm giving a hundred dollars
to someone who follows me on Instagram
I'm gonna be announcing it on my story
all you got to do is follow I'll check
and I'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings